oh hi Internet i'm chris kohler i'm the
video games editor here at wired.com and
we are out in beautiful santa monica
california dating a first look at
bioshock infinite the very very
anticipated follow-up made by the guys
at irrational games to the wonderful
2007 game bioshock and bioshock infinite
taking us to a brand new place for
getting out from under the sea and into
the floating sky world land of columbia
a super patriotic America gone very very
wrong and we are here with ken Garretson
he's the director of product development
at irrational games and hopefully he
will answer several of my questions
about bioshock infinite the brand new
III demo of which we have just seen Tim
thank you for being here hey thanks for
having me so tell us what it is you're
you're showing at e3 kind of give us the
rundown of the demo that we're going to
save sure so this takes place about a
third of the way through the game this
is actually a level called emporia which
is a level where the the founders have
lived the richer people in in columbia
have lived and it's being taken over by
this other group of the Vox Populi who
are the new faction that we're really
introducing with this particular demo
and so this really is a section of
gameplay from from the final game that
you're going to get to partake in I mean
some of the stuff may change by the time
we ship obviously so we're still working
on the game but this is this is a little
taste of another important in the
original BioShock you were the cypher
this this nameless guy and this time
around your appropriate good with booker
dewitt is this X Pinkerton agent he's
this total badass type guy the
Pinkertons were sort of muscle for hire
detectives ah there were Union Buster's
people you would hire when you wanted to
get something done this guy was kind of
dirty though and they kicked him out of
the Pinkertons and so he gets hired by
someone to rescue this girl from
Colombia that's girl Elizabeth and so
for him he figures this is an easy job
he's going to just go get her no problem
bring her home she's been held in this
place for 15 years but it gets a lot
more complicated so he goes to Colombia
rescues we are doing do it fast tell us
about how the skylines you know are used
in gameplay sure I mean we just teased
it in our first demo this time around we
wanted to really show you what is this
life and the ideas I mean these things
are like roller coasters and there's so
much fun to ride out and our focus this
time around on the demo was to really
show you in the fiction of the game
these were freight transport lines that
as a society and the infrastructure is
breaking down within the city people are
using these as a way to get around so
you're going to watch out you get it
free cars they are moving on this thing
it's like being on a railroad track
that's happened to go to seven stories
high and it's so much fun to rising
since you got to be careful and and you
got to watch out to them fly into things
but we're trying to get players choice
you notice there were lines all over the
place you could swap lines as you wanted
jump from line to line you can get
tactical the ED tactical edge on the
people that you're fighting that's
that's what this is all about we didn't
want it to be oh there's a rail section
get online a get off the line be shoot
people in between that just would not be
fun it's not exciting to us or something
gauging we wanted it to really open up
possibilities and do something fun and
allow you to say all right I'm gonna
jump on this line it's going to get me
up to that building you know jump off
that billing get behind these guys and
they get a great shot out but remember
the a ice can navigate these things too
so you got to watch out it's a fluid
situation well we're big fans of
Bioshock acquired we will continue to
follow the development of this game is
tim & Company continue to trickle out
information drop by precious drop until
BioShock Infinite is finally released
sometime in 2012 2012 2012 we will
definitely be there when that happens
Tim thank you very much for being here
today thank you